We all should be aware
of every single person
who dies fighting for
our freedom and democracy
around the world.
Where we're going, Sadr
City, over two million people
lived under a dictator's
boot for 24 years.
And we can build a
better future for them,
for the whole country.
That's why we're going.
You know, we all live
pretty comfortable lives.
We hear things on the
news, and especially
nowadays, when
it's such a sort of
swipe-able, switch-able world.
So now, more than ever, I
think, it's important to tell
these stories.
OK, well--
I love you.
See you.
I think everybody on
this set, actor-wise,
has approached their roles
with a huge level of humility.
And just going, I'm here
in service of the story.
I'm here in service of
these men and women.
We have Comanche Six.
Find a secure defensive position
and wait for extraction.
We're coming.
War affects everyone.
You know, war affects
US soldiers that
are there, in the trenches.
It affects their spouses.
It affects their children.
And that is what
is so important.
I really think is that,
it's not just the soldiers.
It's not just the
military who goes to war.
We all go to war.
Are you sure
you're not worried?
There is one incident in
the entire city last year.
We're not even bringing
the heavy armor.
If there was a gun
going off over there,
it's probably just some fools
celebrating a Cowboys game.
Well, it never hurts
to be extra sure.
I hope what
audiences take away
from this series
is that these are
your soldiers, your families.
This didn't just
happen that one time.
It still happens.